you know insurance is a huge
huge industry like uh two trillion
dollars only in the us
the insure tech portion out of it is
less than one percent so wow that's
basically i think that the category of
it you know the definition of
of a space that is right for innovation
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opwest hello stanford leap and
birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about mobility insurance
meet tomokashi the co-founder and ceo of
voom insurance an insure-tech company
for next generation mobility insurance
products
previously tomer spearheaded
interdisciplinary technology projects
from within the prime minister's office
in israel including a project that has
received the israel defense prize tomer
is a telpo graduate and has a bsc in
computer science and physics from the
hebrew university of jerusalem and an
mba from tel aviv university tomer is
based in tel aviv and is a proud father
of two little daughters
tomakashi welcome to 20 minute leaders
great thank you for having me
it wasn't it wasn't uh easy to to
schedule but i'm really really glad that
we have this opportunity well i know how
incredibly busy you are because what
you're doing with boom insurance is just
growing like crazy and i'm hearing your
beautiful offices i wish you could see
everything that i'm seeing around here
it's a beautiful space and thank you for
hosting me and i'm really excited to get
to know both you better but also
the ensure tech space in general and
where voom is is situated within that we
don't have a lot of time so let's cut
straight to the chase
who are you in a few words and what
leads you to have a strong conviction in
the ensure tech space
great so a little bit about uh myself
i'm tomer the co-founder and ceo of
voong
i'm a computer scientist and physicist
in background that somehow became an
insurance nerd
uh so i started my career in talbiot
as a computer scientist
did my service in the israeli prime
minister's office
first as a programmer then as a project
lead
i led several interdisciplinary projects
so a lot of researchers developers
product people out of work with other
organizations around the world
um and what i liked about what they did
in the prime minister's office is how
interdisciplinary the the problem the
problems were and this is also what i
find
interesting in insurtech uh because the
technology is very important
but also to understand the customers to
understand the other stakeholders such
as rangers to understand the idea you
understand so many things that need to
be a part of the equation for it to
succeed in tel pil i also met with my
co-founder and cto with ori
uh ori aftotel perotti went to dubdevan
uh he used to say that yeah it didn't
change he didn't talk for his mother and
to the band for his father
and after around a decade uh for the
defense forces we we co-founded the vom
together wow
so yeah we we dare to call ourselves uh
friends
amazing now
still now so so before we dive into whom
in sure tech in in essence because you
know insurance is is one of the oldest
industries ever to exist this idea that
you're going to to give somebody you
know the option to feel secure about
their assets and if something happens
then you will get them new assets what
is what what is insurtech you know in
the 21st century
so you know insurance is a huge industry
like uh two trillion dollars only in the
us
the insure tech portion out of it is
less than one percent so wow that's
basically i think that the category of
it you know the definition of
of a space that is right for innovation
less than one percent yeah chinese
market in the us that's uh that's that's
correct unbelievable uh we already saw
some innovation
and
car insurance in home insurance in in
small business insurance
i believe that um
the first way of innovation is basically
disrupting the way that
insurance customers are buying insurance
uh by better delivery better i.t
and the next way what we're entering now
is what i call insurtech 2.0
and that's basically disrupting the
insurance product itself so coming with
different risks model risk models
different uh um
you know things like pay as you go pay
how you drive
things are that are fundamentally
different in the insurance product
itself so not only disrupting the way
that
customers are interacting with the
insurance companies but also disrupting
the risk
and i think that today
in several categories mobility
specifically because things are
increasingly connected there is an
opportunity to to do so and you know
i'll dive into what voom does and maybe
it will give some more context i'm ready
um
so in essence boom is an insured company
that creates distributes insurance
products for the mobility space
so you can think about us like you know
lemonade next hippo uh just for the
mobility world
but especially we focus on unique
products or unique vehicles
where that are actually like overlooked
and neglected by other insurance
companies and hence when we're coming
with our
data-driven usage-based insurance
product there is a big wow effect in the
eyes of the customer because these
customers of these you know unique uh
vehicles were completely neglected by
insurance companies and once we come up
with our solution it's uh you know it's
like an oh my god
uh how did it uh didn't it happen uh
before and then you know i wanna i wanna
be a part of it very very cool uh so if
if you
think about the mobility industry in a
high level i think you can see three
major uh uh shifts
one is new platforms things like uh
drones and e-scooters and many other you
know mobility platforms that now uh
exist in order to
take people from one place to another
will take things from one place to
another
two you have increased connectivity
so the vehicles are becoming
increasingly connected it allows you to
use
much better data that insurers by the
way most cases are blind to in order to
assess the risks it also allows you to
uh do some what's called embedded
insurance to offer the insurance at the
point of sale or even you know from the
dashboard of your of your car so so dive
into it let's let's talk you know
specifics with you know you're talking
about the data driven approach and one
of the things that i think are so
miraculous about what's happening within
short tech and i've seen this from my
end with hippo this idea that through
through new means of data analytics
we're able to assess risk in a much
better way we have much more
transparency into how we form a win-win
relationship with the customer how do
you as voom then use this to your
advantage to be able to take you know
these unique vehicles and and reassess
the risk with them so i think that's a
really really good question because it
doesn't end with the data so accessing
the data is one thing
but being able to use the data
is also a very important uh uh portion
okay so the mobility industries are
always moving
very fast much faster than insurance
okay from an insurance company
perspective
innovation is always hard but but
product innovation is the toughest of
problems
because it's very interdisciplinary you
need to work with the actors with the
risk paper in order to come up with a
risk model
but then let's assume you have like a
safety score for the behavior in in in
in cars or whatnot
then you need to somehow fit it into the
i.t systems from the 80s
that insurance that the insurance
companies have and they have you know
hysterical technical debt
so you know when they have nothing to do
with it and it takes them so so much
time to to really uh create something
and then it doesn't end that there when
you have the insurance point you also
need to distribute it so the insurance
companies in many cases are um
geared toward towards uh our brokers and
you know the more innovative ones are
you know doing some uh direct
distribution
but to really do an omni-channel
distribution at scale including uh uh
embedded insurance increase selling
working with other partners this is
something that is very very uh
challenging
so in order to solve that it's not
it's very hard to solve a specific
problem for the insurance company it's
actually
better to create an insurance company
yourself
that will be end to end and will be in
charge of all of the aspects right okay
so internally at boom and it wasn't an
easy task we really needed to
build from scratch
everything that a modern insurance
company should do
the risk analytics engine
the policy admin system the payments
claims uh
policy creation
reporting and the distribution
uh you know tech right um
and now you know getting back to your
question
there are new sources of data but it's
not it's not only tapping into that it's
always also the ability to you know to
get the data and create something
meaningful with it right and to create a
new insurance product with it and to
deliver to the customers in a way that
they understand it
uh and again it's an extremely
interdisciplinary problem you need
all of the stars to be aligned you know
to create a
a useful product now from the customer's
perspective
the way tell me a little bit about how
customers have been
you know reacting to the insur tech
market but also from the perspective of
voom you mentioned usage based before
which i think is a really interesting
concept that i'd love to understand a
little bit better through your use case
so
how do customers think through
tech and specifically usage based
payment systems yeah okay so maybe we
can dive into one case study of the
first product that we please that we've
created
so the
our first product was for the commercial
drone space okay and they think that
it's a very very good example of a new
vehicle type that was completely
neglected
by traditional insurance companies right
so the same people that insure uh you
know jet planes and and satellites are
the people that were in charge of
insuring uh drones
although it's a completely different
distribution channel completely
different
type of customers right and so on and so
on um and the questions that they asked
are things like you know what's your
engine
how many you know engine hours do you
have uh and things are completely
irrelevant for uh you know basically uh
a flying cell phone right yeah
okay
and
what we did is you know looking at this
opportunity and saying okay that's
something that you know no insurance
companies will really
they
invest
three to five years in order to create
something meaningful right
uh so we started with a usage-based
insurance product for this market uh so
we targeted to begin with the gig
economy
uh commercial drone operators that
needed this you know drone thing uh
just for a specific job think about
wedding photographers engineers and many
others that basically need to show the
certificate of insurance to their
customers to prove that they're insured
right so they have a cute mobile app
that they could um
choose the flight area that they want to
fly in they got a real-time pricing
based on the hazards in their area
so
flying over people flying over roads in
no-fly zones and so on and so on
uh and they could you know get insurance
in you know in the middle of
three clicks
instead of you know filling in paperwork
and waiting for you know two to three
days now what did you learn from you
know from distributing this and watching
the reaction of of the journal operators
so i think i think you know today from
this mobile app today we're the leading
commercial drone insurance provider in
north america in all 50 states and in
canada
uh
one thing that we learned is that it's
very important to uh expand your product
and on the way so we now have like a
monthly and annual policy and we serve
fleets and we provide insurance for
drone light shows and for flying taxis
and from for many other uh use cases
the other thing that we learned from
this drone use case
is is that it doesn't stop there
there are many other overlooked
segments
basically in my mind everything besides
personal order so like personal order is
like almost a definition of uh of a red
ocean all of the insurance companies are
trying to create like an innovative
product there uh with a direct point so
you have progressive and geico and many
other companies right uh and they are
investing more and more money in this
segment yeah uh but all other segments
while they are investing
marketing money in the other segments
the products themselves are you know
pretty
um
old-fashioned yeah okay so rigid annual
policies
no usage based insurance
and you know you could think of
other markets that no one has tapped
into that i think are interesting let's
say let's take motorcycles for example
so
in motorcycles just like in cars and
even more than cars
mileage is a very very important risk
factor
it's almost trivial that the more you
ride
the the riskier the you know
the riskier you are right for the
insurance company
and yet
no insurance company in the world have
created a pay-per-mile motorcycle
insurance product
okay
and
the reasoning for that is not that it's
not a good idea
the problem is that in the eyes of an
insurance company
it makes more sense to put you know 100
million dollars more
in a in the marketing budget just to try
to push the same product
rather than shifting the entire company
to create something that is meaningfully
different and better for the customer
because it's extremely interdisciplinary
you need you know the the actuaries and
the id and the marketing and the
compliance and it's a you know project
of three to five years and that
insurance company and the technology
especially the technology right because
of the idea that because you know it's
like everything is you know spaghetti
code yeah that uh uh is really really
hard to to change
uh and hence
you could think about categories that
for insurance companies are relatively
small
but for startups these are you know
multi-billion dollars
markets
that are again ripe for innovation
no one is there uh
and
you really have a wall effect in the
eyes of the customer because it's
something really different it's not that
you know it's easier to purchase the
policy and the you know and the
color of the logo is different and uh it
has a fresh looking fit which are all
extremely important it's also the
product itself is different is that
for a significant segment
of the customer base uh you don't really
need to pay for the others uh
you pay only for what you use and you
have a cheaper rate in many cases
amazing now what did you learn over your
over your time in rooms so far that
perhaps somebody from the outside it
won't be trivial for them in regards to
the insurtech space whether it's from
the consumer behavior standpoint from
from investors standpoint from our other
interesting players
i think i think it's you know insurance
in general you can
basically um refine the entire product
into two specific moments and everything
else is uh
almost uh irrelevant
one is how easy it is to purchase the
product
and two how easy it is to get the claim
to get money if you have a claim okay
so if you master these two pivotal
moments
then everything else is uh is easy
and i think that the good insured
companies
that have refined these two
moments
also sit in the net for mortal score
okay so
the average net promoter score in
insurance is
you know even the 20s
wow
and
when you see companies like uh like
women like a few other insurgents we
have a net promoter score of over 70.
okay so it's you know at pa with uh with
amazon and apple wow so that's
extremely
uh important wow
um another thing that i think is uh uh
relevant for insurtech but uh relevant
for
you know
startups in general
is uh and you know everybody says that
but it's very important very true
culture it's strategy for for breakfast
so i think that the people that
are part of the company
uh and the culture and the way that they
think
and we have you know we have a saying in
the company uh
i think it's never it's never not my
problems
i think everybody thinks not only about
their job domain
but also about you know the other
adjacent things that other people are
doing okay so the product is very
involved in the r dna marketing the
marketing is very involved in the design
and the and the product and that's very
very important and crucial and this is
exactly the the secret sauce
that the small focus in suretech has
right and many other you know existing
players that with huge budgets do not
have now so so if we look two three
years down the line
with the vision
where where is the company like boom
where is it headed or where is the
insured tax space headed in general
so we believe that the mobility industry
is is is just shifting tremendously okay
and the
amount of new products new opportunities
for ensure tech in the new mobility
space is
much more than 100 billion dollars in
premiums just in the u.s wow
and that's you know that's the category
we live in
uh we're going to and we're already
creating a suite of products
for the new mobility emerging mobility
world uh just like we did in dross and
we have several products now in the
pipeline that we're going to launch uh
some of them this year some of them the
next year and that's always the future i
love it well tomorrow thank you for for
letting me and hosting me in this in
this beautiful office and and you know
sharing your your insights with me about
the the insurance space and specifically
we might have a few more questions about
you not about voom or insurtech and i
want to take you back really quick to
your childhood but you know as as you're
going about your life what what really
interests you what was some maybe a
hobby or a specific lesson at school
so you know as a kid like i had good
grades
but i wasn't really a good uh uh student
interesting uh i was you know one of
those people that are skipping most of
classes interesting uh i was very very
fortunate to be in a in a gifted class
so from the third grade to the 12th
grade
i uh actually studied with the same
people it's like a group of 20 people
that some of them are friends of mine uh
until today wow a few of them are you
know also uh founders of uh startup so
it's a great network from the third
grade uh very important one uh and you
know what fascinates me is just you know
being with friends yeah much more like
you know the trivial answer would be to
say you know i was fascinated about math
computer science physics not true uh i
was just about friends yeah i love it
and and what inspires you today as you
go about your daily life
so
i think
that's actually something that inspires
me today is
not a part of the in short tech or
entrepreneurship world
i think that the most inspiring event
that happened
in the last year is uh the vaccination
to covet
uh i think what you know pfizer and
modena and others have done
is you know um you know truly
not like not only do you know
life-saving event
but also you know world-saving events so
because like the entire
ecosystem has changed because of the
vaccination i love it and what are three
words you would use to describe yourself
wow okay so that's uh that's a good
question i would i would start with
curious
uh
i think that i'm really really curious
about things uh in life
that's also what you know made me
uh got in getting into insurtech
you know just an industry that i knew
nothing about and this is why i like so
much to get into
also every time i'm meeting with a new
founder uh with i'm asking about their
business because
i have a keen interest in what they do
uh and i think this is something that uh
that you know beats me uh a lot
the second thing is i would say hard
work
uh
today it's like you know common to talk
about uh uh you know work-life balance
it's common to talk about you know you
need to work smart and not hard
uh
i think that work-life balance is
important i think that it's much more
important to work smart than to work
hard
but it's also very important to work
hard uh and
just you know be
very aggressive
and very uh ambitious about what you do
because
if you don't move fast enough
specifically in the startup world
someone with uh eat your lunch
especially today
and
the
third one
that is actually like the opposite of
the second one
is a family man
so i have a wonderful wife
uh also a career woman
uh and two
amazing amazing daughters
and i really think that
you can combine hard work
with being a family person and uh
it's not one thing or the other
usually it uh comes on the expense of
your sleep
but uh you can combine these two i love
it
this was amazing best of luck with room
and thank you for sharing the time with
me thank you very much